all right guys bang bang I've got plenty
here my wife my best friend and also the
author of hidden genius these secret
ways of thinking that power of the
world's most successful people before we
talk about the book uh we went to Barnes
Noble over the weekend and when we went
to Barnes Noble you went right I went
left we were looking for the book
because someone had messaged you and
said that they saw a book that was in
their Barnes and Noble which it wasn't
supposed to be the book technically
comes out today but Barnes Noble cheated
they jumped the gun they pump faked
everyone and put some of the books out
so we went of course because we gotta go
see is it in our local Barnes Noble and
when you went right you ended up
empty-handed that is a lesson for Life
usually I went left and I found the book
and I caught I caught on video you
walking over and seeing it for the first
time what were you feeling
it was crazy mainly because I was not
only was I not expecting to see it
because I was like oh like one local
Barnes Noble made the decision to put
out some books because they got a
shipment early but I was like surely
it's not gonna be here and I was in the
non-fiction section so like I was
looking at the books I didn't see it so
I just started perusing and I wasn't
looking at my phone and then you came
over and you're like I just texted you
and I saw the text
that's like a normal thing in our
relationship and I went over
and I was like I thought I thought you
were messing with me that's why I was
like wait what why would I ever do that
for the record the reason why when you
went right you were wrong and I went
left and I was right is you went to the
old non-fiction which of course the book
wouldn't be there I went to the new
non-fiction the real releases yeah we
found it all right let's get into the
book uh I just want to throw out a bunch
of people that are in the book and a
bunch of topics uh I've heard over the
years you talk about some of these
things but this is the first time you've
put it all together into one single
resource uh Alter Ego I always tell
people this and I never give you credit
because I want to feel smart explain
what's going on with alter ego and why
so many successful people have an alter
ego yeah so I discovered this when I
personally started
um doing a lot more like public speaking
and interviewing people on stage and I
had never done that before and I was
really nervous but then
I started doing this kind of thing where
like I was like okay well I'm really you
know shy and introverted and kind of
nervous like in my real life but when
I'm on stage I have to like put on a
show for the audience audience doesn't
want to see somebody who's like nervous
and not confident so I kind of had in my
head this idea of like confident Paulina
on stage and it's funny because like
when I went on stage and I started
interviewing the person it felt almost
as if like this other thing took over
and suddenly I had the confidence and it
was easy and whatever
um so I was like I wonder if this is
actually a thing and when I started
researching a lot of these people I
found that for example Beyonce who you
think is like this Powerhouse we went to
her concert you saw fire fire uh she
Jay-Z was there two boys don't worry
yeah but Beyonce was the main um show uh
she uh the way she presents on stage I
mean she's super confident you would
never ever think that she's actually
incredible introverted and shy in real
life and she's like to create that
Persona and dress like that and dance
like that I would never do that in my
normal life so I had to create this
version
um this aspirational almost like ideal
version of herself called Sasha Fierce
she gave her a name yeah so Sasha fears
on stage Beyonce off stage uh Kobe
Bryant during the lowest moments in his
career when he was like being booed on
the court he was like you know what I'm
when people are saying boo Kobe he's
like I'm not going out there as Kobe I'm
going out there's the Black Mamba this
like snake killer yeah exactly so he it
didn't affect him in the same way as if
he identified as Kobe David goggin same
thing he doesn't identify as David
Goggins because he says David was a weak
kid he was bullied he was insecure
whatever I'm Goggins and he said he
likes to say that he was uh built not
born and now just attest to the fact
that like you can create your identity
and the person you are today does not
have to be the person you are tomorrow
and yesterday you actually introduced me
to a new person who had an alter ego
Brian Dawkins that's right last night
Paulina was talking about Alter Ego I
said sit down right here young child let
me pull up YouTube Let Me Show from The
Archives of the internet and I pulled up
some Brian Dawkins highlights where he
has two lockers one is Brian Dawkins
physically has two locks like and the
other Locker is Weapon X and he talks
about how when he goes on the field he's
in Brian Dawkins that's Weapon X yeah
but I will say something really
interesting
um over time it's possible for yourself
to get closer to the to your
aspirational self to where they are one
so for example Beyonce was being
interviewed by Oprah and she told her by
the way like I killed Sasha Fierce Sasha
Fierce doesn't exist anymore because
this is who I am now like I am confident
I don't need this extra psychological
crutch to carry me on stage I'd like to
report a homicide
all right uh let's talk about Nim's
Persia uh in the book you talk quite a
bit about uh the ability to handle risk
and especially in times of uncertainty
uh Nims is probably one of the best
examples of this in the world where he
continues to climb these mountains he's
probably one of the best Mountaineers
climbers whatever you want to call them
uh in the world and in the book he
basically says like nothing that you
plan goes as planned on the mountain so
what can we take away from him
specifically yeah I want to talk about
him and then I want to
talk to idea so Nims submitted 14 Death
Zone Peaks it had never been done before
and the um and the amount of time I
think the last time it took like 14
years or something insane but it took
Nims six months and six days to Summit
all 14 Peaks which is absolutely insane
if you haven't seen the Netflix film
it's great well he also did crazy stuff
during it like he was climbing the
mountains and he was doing it for time
but I think at least once maybe twice
they would call him and be like hey Nims
I know you're like in the middle of this
uh race essentially against yourself but
like there's somebody stuck on the
mountain will you go back and get them
and he would go back and actually get
them and carry them down yeah he uh he
like gave some of his oxygen to someone
who was who needed oxygen on the
mountain and that's really really
dangerous because if you miscalculate
something it's he calls it a suicide
mission
um but yeah he he's done all of that uh
but Nim's like his whole idea is that
you have to be incredibly competent and
prepared before undertaking something
like this because nothing ever goes as
planned so if your body's not right if
your mind's not right and one tiny thing
goes wrong again a suicide mission
um so so his whole thing is like
competence is the key to doing these um
insane challenges and is it competence
is the mitigator to risk yes
website to that
to that's about how
three sides he says that there's the
odds you will get hit the average
consequences of getting hit in the tail
end consequences of getting hit so you
can mitigate the first two the last one
is kind of like if you're an investor if
you're any if you're just a human living
life there will be unforeseen risk and
that risk could be a Black Swan event it
could be a global pandemic
um but he talks about how that tail end
risk has the least likelihood to happen
but the most impact and it's the one you
cannot really prepare for so another
Mountaineer is Conrad anchor who I talk
about in in the book he incredibly
competent he's a legendary Mountaineer
him and two buddies were climbing Mount
shishapangma and they were I believe
close to the top when all of a sudden an
unforeseen event happened and Avalanche
just came down and
um it was so close and they had so
little time to prepare that he went to
the left and his buddies went to the
right so there's three people standing
there and they saw the Avalanche coming
and they basically were like run run and
like pick a side yeah like I'm out like
that's a nightmare scenario exactly so
so it's like so Conrad had like a broken
collarbone he suffered head lacerations
but his buddies weren't found their
bodies weren't found for a number of
years so it's like that one stupid dumb
luck decision that you made in that
really really
consequential uh event saved his life so
it's like yes you can prepare all you
want you can be as competent as you want
and you can make all the right decisions
but that doesn't mean that you will get
the outcome that I'm playing 3D chess
with you you know how oh God because I
went left in the store and you went to
the right no I went left you went right
survival death I'm just saying hey I'm
just making the connections all right
let's talk about Amelia Boone I think
Courtney doll Walter uh both of them
they love pain yeah this is like this is
crazy both of them are these like ultra
marathon runners uh I think that Amelia
Boone if I remember correctly she talks
about like becoming friends with pain
and Courtney doll Walter calls it like
the pain cave what's going on with these
women yeah I think Amelia Boone's
nickname is the queen of pain
um so they both kind of uh are masterful
it's separating pain and suffering but
Amelia and they both personify pain
which I think is really important Amelia
um when she talks about like during a
Tough Mudder race she'll have something
go wrong her ankle her you know whatever
and she's like instead of listening to
myself I start talking to myself and the
distinction here is when you listen to
yourself you're like oh my God my foot
hurts oh my God how am I gonna get
through the next 10 miles whatever but
when you talk to yourself you're giving
yourself the thoughts that you want to
think and put into your head so you're
like uh hey my foot hurts but um but
like you're good foot like you literally
personify the foot is a is a separate
entity from you so it doesn't feel as
personal
um Courtney
is fascinating I mean she takes I watch
this interview with her with Joe Rogan
where Joe kept trying to get her to like
talk in depth about like oh but tell me
philosophically and she's like nope I
just do it
um she's very matter of fact and she
sees pain as a place so she's like when
I'm running these Hundred Mile races
she's had severe nausea she's had a
bleeding head injury she's had a broken
foot she's had it all but she's pushed
through it and they're like how how is
that even possible and she says that in
her head she visualizes like the pain
cave is there I know I'm approaching it
as she approaches it she's like okay
it's I'm in it uh
things hurt really bad but by thinking
of it as a place you're in control of
when you enter it and you're equally as
in control when you leave so she's like
I I know that eventually I'm gonna be on
the other side so she doesn't and can I
just add something here the
personification of pain
is really really important uh because it
builds mental toughness and I've noticed
that Courtney Don Walter does this with
the pain cave
um David Goggins does this with again a
place a dark room he's like I go in the
dark room as David Goggins I look at
myself in the mirror and I face myself
and I say you're fat you're lazy you're
a liar what are you gonna do about it
he there's a transformation that happens
in there and then he leaves and becomes
Goggins uh Anthony Ray Hinton he was
somebody who wasn't seeking out pain
voluntarily he was shoved in there
against his will when he spent 30 years
on death row
um and he was something he didn't do or
something he didn't do he was wrongfully
yeah uh imprisoned but he watched 54 men
walk past his cell to get executed by
electrocution and he managed to keep his
mind sane and he was in oftentimes in
solitary confinement in a tiny tiny cell
by himself again a place of suffering
and pain
um and he says that in that place he
used his mind for good so he would
visualize traveling to England having
tea with the queen winning Wimbledon
marrying Halle Berry things like that
that allowed him to escape his current
reality and the the importance of this
is that by visualizing pain as a place
it's almost like you're you're one type
of person you go into this place of
metamorphosis and you transform into
somebody else and David goggin says
basically in that dark room if you don't
break you'll transform and that's the
case of all these people so let's talk
about Bob Bowman and Michael Phelps this
is the craziest thing I think
I mean Michael Phelps jumps in the water
I think at the Olympics and while he's
in the water he gets water in his
goggles now I'm not a goggles guy but if
I was wearing goggles and I got water in
my eyes I'm done I'm gonna stand up put
my feet on the ground I'm gonna take the
goggles off I'm gonna you know dangle
them out there get the water to drip out
gentlemen is why Anthony isn't at the
Olympics yes exactly and then I put the
goggles back on I would kind of do each
nose make sure I get my the water out of
my ears and I'd keep swimming yeah and I
would lose but he kept swimming with the
water in his goggles explain how he did
that and why he was so prepared he
basically did it blind right like the
reason he was able to do it blind is
because
his coach Bob Bowman for many many years
basically his main coach throughout his
career
um Wanted Michael to undergo uncertainty
and create these uh rehearsals for what
could go wrong and how could he how he
could react so during practice he would
break his goggles and Michael Phelps
away what the hell he's like I want you
to know how to pace yourself with breath
and Counting Strokes instead of using
visuals to get you to the other side so
and and again like at the Olympics the
unexpected happens he gets water in his
goggles now he knows oh yeah I did that
when he broke my Gog also now I can like
count strokes and know exactly where the
wall is and where I need to turn it's
it's really hard to do but that's why
he's the best he won the gold medal so
he did this blindfolded essentially and
won the gold medal yeah which tells you
that he's just one dominant but two also
is prepared it's competence builds
confidence competence builds confidence
I like that all right Jim coke uh cook
Coke cook whatever whatever his name is
Boston beer company uh he
basically took this like big leap of
faith to start a business but he was
rich before and he was making what like
the equivalent of a million bucks in
today's dollars he just quit his job I
was like I'm gonna go like be a beer
brewer so they call him beer Brews all
right what's his story
um his story is basically Jim Cook was
in his late 30s making 250 000 a year at
Boston Consulting Group which is a
million dollars which is equivalent
thanks inflation
um but he he was um so so at the time he
was the only one in his lineage of
people because the cooks came from
Germany in the 1840s to the US and each
eldest son
um became a beer brewer and there were
Big Beer people in Germany and at the
time in the 90s there was a joke that uh
water is stronger than America tell the
real joke come on let's go you're giving
us the watered down version no pun
intended tell us the real joke but like
some people don't get okay I'll say
trust me my audience will understand the
audience is the writer they like
sections
um so they said uh uh she's so
uncomfortable
the joke is the joke is
um okay so the joke is that American
Beer is like making love in a canoe too
[__] close to water
so American Beer basically it was very
close to water so it didn't have flavor
it wasn't like German beer and it was
um known that European beer was so much
more dominant uh so Jim was like well
what if we change that what if we make
American Beer that's flavorful and and
good and like people really like it
so he was rummaging through the family
attic when he found his great great
grandfather's original beer recipe from
Germany and he was like well what if I
take this and create an American Beer
um he told his dad his idea and his dad
was like Jim you're making 250k at
Boston Consulting Group this is the
dumbest effing idea I've ever heard so
um
so he was like okay but he was really
bored at BCG so then but he had a hard
time he had a kid he had a wife he had a
mortgage he was like
am I really going to quit this amazing
salary and go start something that I
don't even know if it's gonna work
um so he started asking himself the
question is what I'm doing scary or is
it dangerous and the difference between
scary and dangerous and I use this
framework all the time in my life is
that if you do the scary thing the scary
thing is only scary for like a few days
you're scared to tell your boss you're
scared your college professor will be
disappointed in your decision you're
scared what your friends will say but
dangerous is you looking back when
you're 80 being like damn I wish I
started that beer brewing company so he
ended up deciding that he didn't want to
stay in the dangerous situation he
wanted to take the scary right
let's talk storytelling there's this uh
famous profile I guess uh or article
that was written uh gay talise I think
is how you pronounce the guy's name who
wrote it uh he went out he was going to
go uh meet Frank Sinatra Legend
profile but he had a cold and uh he
writes this line I wrote it down to make
sure that I don't forget it because it's
perfect it says Sinatra with a cold is
Picasso without paint Ferrari without
fuel fire like gay talise if he had
Twitter be viral every single day uh
explain like the importance of
Storytelling he could have just been
like yo Frank Sinatra had a cold so I
didn't get to talk to him right but
instead he hits us with fire line so not
sure what the cold it's Picasso without
paint Ferrari without fuel yeah how
important is the storytelling today's
day and age where everyone seems to have
very low attention spans yeah so um so
Frank Sinatra has a cold is like the
gold standard of profile writing uh gay
talise actually uh pioneered a new form
of Journalism called narrative
non-fiction because huh what is that
yeah before before this before that
profile the way that profiles and just
news articles were written where it was
very formulaic and it was very dry he
introduced fiction elements to tell a
non-fiction story so that's why it reads
like that it's very full of detail in
context and nuance and he should it's so
ironic that the best profile and the
gold standard of profiles he never
talked to the subject but it shows like
how it can be done he talked to like a
hundred people in Frank Sinatra's orbit
so he was able to get even a better
portrait of the man than if he just
talked to him
um and then uh and then in terms of
Storytelling I think a lot of us think
that this day and age there's like
I was talking to Anthony scaramucci
yesterday and he was like you know today
the mooch the mooch uh he said today we
can barely agree on what the facts are
let alone like anything else and I was
like but that's not because we're not
agreeing on what the facts are that's
because we have conflicting stories of
what we believed the facts say in our
interpretation of the facts not the
facts themselves
um and so in the book I talk about these
like incredible storytellers one of them
being Aaron Sorkin he's very well known
for
um The Social Network the film and which
is Mark Zuckerberg in the Inception of
Facebook and the way he uh talks about
it he was interviewed about it and he
was like I wasn't particularly
interested in Tech or startups or
Venture Capital anything like that what
drew me to this story in particular were
that there were um three different or
two different lawsuits that had three
different versions of the truth so
Eduardo was suing him the Winklevoss
Twins were suing him and then Mark had
to defend himself all three parties had
different stories and um the way he and
he was like and by the way with the film
I didn't want to be like here's the
ultimate source of Truth he was like I
wanted to show all these competing
versions of the truth which I think he
does very well in the film
um and he says to get a great story
basically story equals conflict plus
intent so he says the best stories have
conflict that is laced with intent when
you tell a good story and you only talk
about the problem but not what the
protagonist's intent is it makes no
sense so he's like
Mark Zuckerberg his goal wasn't you know
money or wealth it was freaking social
status and he was willing to plow
through anything to get that and um any
obstacle the Obstacle of the Winklevoss
twins his friend Eduardo his girlfriend
at the time or the institution that is
Harvard he was willing to get through
anything to get to his final destination
and make Facebook this thing because he
didn't get an invite to a fancy social
socialist club for those that don't know
about Aaron sorkin's uh early life they
should go and learn about the guy was
just he was an addict he never slept he
was doing cocaine like every night and
basically he would go to like a
different
uh
like World essentially and he would sit
there and he all night would just write
and he said that he was scared that it
without his addiction he wouldn't be
good but I think that actually stopped
him if I remember correctly is that he
got caught at the airport at TSA with
his child there and that's kind of what
yeah it reminds me a lot of like Hunter
S Thompson's uh life that guy's a legend
there's a lot of writers who are addicts
yeah well Hunter S Thompson attic would
be one description but if you ever look
at Hunter S Thompson's daily schedule
it's insane like how the guy live all
right let's move to uh somebody who's an
addict but not for drugs uh Tom Brady he
has a quote in the book you gotta limit
inflation in the body whether it's
through your diet inflammation what I
say inflation but you gotta limit
inflation too that is an important thing
you see how my brain works you gotta
limit inflammation in the body whether
it's through diet nutrition or your
thoughts right diet nutrition cool got
it but thoughts is an interesting thing
you gotta limit inflammation in your
body through your thoughts what's that
mean it's um I have this idea of like a
Content diet
um that actually you helped me develop
uh but the idea that like
helped is is kind for you go ahead for
example when we met I was watching a lot
of like reality television which
included like The Bachelor The
Bachelorette like all these all these
shows that
basically when you put that garbage in
your brain
um it like you see the world through a
different lens so you're constantly like
is he mad at me is she mad at me uh did
I say something wrong did I it's like
through the lens of relationships in a
very negative way and then you realize
that like you're not putting difficult
um material on your brain so you're just
kind of like consuming junk food content
and what break the example just so
people are clear because I got you on my
show now so I can I can hold you hostage
this is really is uh no if you sit and
you watch a bunch of people arguing on
television all day long then naturally
whether you realize it implicitly or not
or explicitly or not is that then you go
argue a lot with the people in your life
because you're basically mirroring what
you just watched on television so if you
just put in your head all day long
idiots you know 25 women chasing one
dude and then you go into your real life
you start arguing with people it's like
wait hold on a second like take the
garbage out of your brain right let's
put good information in yeah which I had
to learn too right like I would read
stupid stuff or watch stupid stuff
whatever and then you quickly learn like
oh if there's like high quality stuff
that goes in then actually your actions
the output ends up being high quality as
well yeah and it's not just um it like
that's not to say that all you read and
all you listen to and whatever is just
really difficult material that makes you
think it's okay to have a sliver of that
but just don't make it like your entire
food content pyramid it's like dessert
you could do it like once a week and
you're good yeah yeah and um I I want to
touch on this thing that so
yes like a Content diet is determined by
what you read what you listen to what
you what you watch but one thing that I
actually learned from you is that is
that um a part of your content diet is
also who you hang out with because those
conversations then lead to thoughts
which then lead to beliefs so if you
surround yourself with people who maybe
like are your high school buddies that
you know don't you don't have that much
in common with anymore you end up
staying on surface level conversations
but when you have friends who you can
actually talk about really interesting
subjects with you get new ideas it's a
much healthier uh content and way to
live but um and can I add something real
quick since you said that I taught you
okay okay
is well I think that they're I think
that there's a uh somewhat acceptance of
this thing like don't surround yourself
with people who talk about people
surround yourself with people who talk
about ideas for uh has been talked about
often
um but it's also surround yourself with
people who have different life
experiences and so one of the things
throughout my entire life is I kind of
feel like uh I made bus stops right like
I was on the bus and I went and okay
cool I was in high school I met a bunch
of amazing people still to this day I
think very highly of them right and they
all had a similar experience to me in
high school but then I got on the bus
and they all went to a lot of the same
schools I went to a completely different
school to a different bus stop right met
a bunch of people there that I went into
the army and then I went to uh Silicon
Valley and then I went you know and I
kind of went to all these different bus
stops and I kind of collected friends so
I'm still in touch with many people at
those different bus stops but I never
was like all in on one bus stop I never
thought of okay this is the only thing
that I'm gonna do I want the variety of
experience and I want the different
knowledge to take with me and in some
way like the bus got smarter yeah as we
kept going down the road right yeah and
then there's another
um put that in your book well I did but
no there's another thread in that that I
don't know if it's in your little
questions to ask but I have a chapter on
clarifying your thinking and I you know
how fascinated with Colts and like the
people who join Cults I definitely think
that if you want to admit that publicly
yeah it's in the box so
um so I think like
I think that a lot of people who uh
right now we live in a very tribal
society and and James Clear one time was
like you know why it's so hard for
people to change their beliefs even if
they think that like their beliefs are
absurd it's because uh when you're
asking somebody to change their beliefs
you're essentially asking them to change
their tribe and very few people are like
oh I'm gonna these are my friends I'm
gonna go like make friends with another
group that's not how it works and I
think what you just said about the bus
stops is like the reason that you and I
don't have really strong beliefs about
one thing
um is because for example for me like I
was born in Bulgaria I grew up in
Atlanta Georgia I moved to New York as
an adult I
kind of always feel like an outsider but
also not just that I've had a multitude
of experiences and I've seen how
different people think so I can
understand why they make the decisions
they can make therefore I like Aaron
Sorkin I don't see something as like the
ultimate source of truth I see it more
of like a gray Scale based on your past
experiences and I think what you just
said like if you hadn't had those
experiences where you went to one school
you went to war you came back like those
are all things that shape your mind and
you're like oh I this one tribal group
isn't the only source of truth there's
so many other ways to think I went to
six schools in 12 years oh yeah it's
crazy I never even thought of it that
way all right uh I want to talk about
one more thing uh Bruno cuccinelli which
you found real early in our relationship
lifetime whatever and the king of
Kashmir the king of Kashmir uh not to be
confused with our boy the wolf in
Cashmere God who is that uh lvmh guy
I'm so I'm just looking I got a big
brain some stuff stays in there I think
that's one of them uh all right so Bruno
cuccinelli says that he re-reads uh what
is his name Brunello sorry cuccinelli uh
he re-reads every year Marcus aurelius's
uh meditations famous book been around
for thousands of years this dude got the
same problems that we got today trying
to figure out himself and obviously he's
writing his meditations down on uh
probably parchment at the time now we
have a digital
um but he says that the reason why he
reads it every single year is because
each year he's a different person and he
gets different things out of it so in
his 20s he learned some things and his
30s other things were more important in
his 40s and 50s whatever explainly how
people can use that in their everyday
life to actually improve and compound
over time yeah well again like if you
read a certain book a lot of us when
we're excited about a book we tend to
speed read through it this was the best
book ever but how often do you go back
and reread it and I found myself the
same thing that Brunello talks about is
like when you reread a book at a
different stage in your life you're able
to pull out different things that you
never saw the the time before uh for
example let's say you read it for the
first time in your 20s and then when you
read it in your 30s now you have kids
and you're like looking at it through
the lens of a parent and you're taking
away different
um things that you might as you might
have when you were 20.
all right now that we're good with the
book let me close my uh notes here so
hidden genius the secret ways of
thinking that power the world's most
successful people this is plaina's first
book says planet marinova pompliano on
the cover very long name now welcome uh
and there's uh James Clear says a gold
mine of actionable ideas and useful
advice from Top performers in all Fields
James clear for those of you don't know
author of the number one bestseller
Atomic habits we then go on the back
here we've got Morgan Hazel housel
Brandon Stanton Danny Meyer Patty
sellers cat Cole and James known as Jim
O'Shaughnessy I like to use James though
and so the book as of today is on
bookshelves Before I Let You Go I want a
prediction or a guess how many books do
we think get sold in the first week and
in the first year I will also
guess and then we will see who's closer
this is I know this is like your worst
nightmare but we're we're gonna do it ah
why would I ever do that
what do you think it's like I don't do
price for it you know you guys
predictions I don't do book predictions
Book Sales predictions
can we hit number one on Amazon I would
love to hit number one on Amazon what's
the highest in pre-sales did you get on
the pre-sales yeah during the pre-sale
period what was the highest you got on
the list oh I got to number 500. oh all
right that's easy yeah now the book's
live Let's go people let's go people
yeah I would love to all right so all
people have to do is they go either on
Amazon and they buy it or the local
bookstore go to local bookstore support
local I got it support independent
that's right and if they do it and they
take a photo and they tweet it at you do
they get anything
um well
for the people
already
take it from the end back to the
beginning and take a nice little
storytelling here
um when we went to Barnes and Noble you
went right death I went left life and uh
we found those books you were taken over
with emotion I on the other hand being
the amazing being the amazing husband
and father that I am was chasing our
daughter around the store as she tried
to grab every book off the shelf I would
dive and knock it back in so that there
was no damage to the store because I
want to buy all these stupid books that
I didn't want uh
I wouldn't let you leave the store until
you signed them yeah and you because I
think
permission hold on hold on I just want
people to understand
the pain the pain cave I live in every
day
Sinatra with the cold pop at the
bookstore don't worry listen to this
and I got a pen from the people and to
get a pen I said hey my wife wrote a
book The book's over there she's going
to sign them can I have a pen please
they said oh no problem here's the pen
okay I took the pen I brought it to you
and then you because you're a nerd you
are a nurse
permission hold on you sat there and
you're like I can't sign the book unless
I go and I ask for permission I said
it's your book sign the book put it back
on the show nobody knows that but I need
to ask for permission what if they get
mad at me tell them it's my book there's
no but I have to ask for permission and
we stood there for five minutes of my
life I was in the pain cave negotiating
with basically a book terrorist who
wouldn't sign the books until she got
permission
yes for the record I triumphantly
convinced her to sign the books you
signed them I tweeted it and was like
hey go get it and next you know people
were like hey I wouldn't I picked it up
yeah that was really cool thank you so
much I people did go and they did buy
the sign books
um it was really cool now that's what we
call them the show biz a setup because I
just want everyone who's watching on
video to know that the book that I have
right here
is also signed excited to take you on a
Learning Adventure
any last words for the people what did
you think of the book I thought the book
was fantastic I am only offended for two
things throughout this entire process
one I was not asked for a quote for the
front or back cover my quotes were
relegated to in private I think it's
excellent I would have had some fire but
you know it's all right I'm not as big
as James clear and all these other fine
people uh and then the second thing is
uh I've actually read the book about 17
times uh but I never actually picked up
the book and opened it until now when it
was about to be and I have listened 17
times do you read it to me every single
individual chapter you want to improve
your writing read it out loud because
you'll your ears catch mistakes that
your eyes Miss correct so I got read the
book 17 times but then
I went to another pain cave and for the
last four months
every day Paulina has asked me are you
gonna read the physical book yet are you
gonna read the physical book yet and now
I have the reason I have is because I
was waiting for now it's show time now
it's showtime you were doing the
pre-sale stuff now it is time to sell
books oh man we're gonna get this book
and every single person's hands and I
think that the measure of success is if
people put it on their little
bookshelves and when they're on Zoom you
see you see it there and it's like a
status symbol I just like yeah I read
the book yeah but see like to me it's
more like I don't know I when you read
the book I would love to hear your
feedback but like if it if something
resonated with you and it genuinely
changed something that you do or a habit
or something for the better let me know
like those are this that that means so
much more to me it is the difference
between you and I it's like I see a
number and I'm like oh there's a game to
play how many books can you sell and
you're like I don't care about the book
sales I just want people to like learn
from this book I really do all right
where can we send people to find the
book hidden genius book Dot
or Amazon
and it goes right there buys all right
uh my book says uh no price on it how
much is it
um well uh it depends where you live
okay twenty seven dollars damn y'all
trying to get smart euros dollars okay
all right all right and where can we
find uh you on the internet you can find
me on Twitter at at
what do you call that it's an ad symbol
oh okay uh Paulina underscore marinova
because freaking I have a long thing
with Twitter so I found playing in my
DMs all right guys great episode I
really appreciate it
I appreciate you coming and doing this
it was a very far walk for you uh it's
just a pleasure to get to meet you and
learn from you so I hope everyone goes
and buys a book it was a pleasure
um getting to answer your questions we
could work on your presence a little bit
on your podcasting um
presence you need an alter ego you do
that is your I do I didn't want to bring
it up earlier but just real quick maybe
we'll end on this you probably don't
realize this but every morning when I
wake up yeah I got white pants on yeah
I'm not sad but I am sad I got white
pants
you don't realize this but every morning
when I get up out of bed I know it's
dark and everything right but you don't
see me I pick up my left leg and then I
pick up my right leg you never see me do
this and put your pants on my pants on
one leg at a time Anthony woke up I had
to get in my pump suit let's go hit the
Dead
she's so embarrassed she's so
embarrassed this is like I love you
congratulations the book's amazing
everyone go get it hidden genius see you
guys next time thank you
thank you